there were reports today that they broke
up do you
Tom
you are in love
she was sending letters to my house like
four days ago Ariana Maddox speaks out
after Tom Sandoval and Raquel Levis call
it quits it was like you threw it all up
in the air and you've got to see where
it lands moments after the shocking
Vanderpump Rules season 10 finale I mean
Raquel became like really good friends I
don't give up
hour as The skandival Saga enters its
final chapter don't even look at me you
don't deserve to look at this there was
nothing left unset the 37 year old
reality star stopped by Watch What
Happens live on Wednesday after a source
confirmed to E.T Tom and Raquel broke up
host Andy Cohen asked Ariana for her
reaction I don't buy that at all she was
sending letters to my house like four
days ago so really what in the written
letters well I didn't open it it's a
crime you know so but it was addressed
to him and it was her hand she was
sending letters to Tom from her
treatment facility I guess I don't know
and they are sitting on his bed waiting
for him
hi guys Bravo cameras picked back up
with news of the affair broke in March
everyone in the season 10 finale wonders
if the signs were there all along the
person I questioned six years ago in
Miami we had sex
that he had cheated with it's this girl
from Miami they slept together it was
before he and I were exclusive
and I didn't want people to think the
absolute worst of the man I thought I
was going to spend the rest of my life
with so I defended him another blast
from the past the gang's former co-star
Billy Lee a few years ago I heard the
rumors that Tom and Billy Lee go off and
do whatever they go and do in the
Affairs aftermath Billy was sad that
people are so fixated on picking aside
as both of her friends were hurting in
their own ways Jesse Montana said that
you guys oh my God no way he did that
meanwhile Ariana has since unfollowed
Billy on Instagram and her co-star Lala
Kent wants answers we need to open that
case back up it went cold and I don't
think it need to be cold no more Billy
and Tom were also snapped spending time
together last month two weeks before
Ariana told T what she's learned about
herself from scandival that I can do any
that can handle anything
[Music]
right now is the mess I don't know if we
can sort it out I know you don't think
we can but hey I have hope what would it
take for you to forgive either Tom or
Raquel
that's not happening
[Applause]